you cannot change conditions or
circumstance you don't have to let them
control you we can't control what's
going on outside but we can control
what's going on inside unfortunately I
don't think many of us have been raised
to really understand that and it's a
lack of understanding that's causing all
our problems we are the only creature on
the planet that's totally disoriented in
our environment other little squirrels
the birds the every all the animals are
completely at home in their environment
they blend in you and I are totally
disoriented in our environment we've
been given the mental faculties to
create our own environment however we go
right through school and we've never
learned that we have higher faculties
and the average person has no knowledge
of how to operate with them their
perception the will reason imagination
memory and intuition those mental
faculties they're not just words they're
actually mental faculties that we can
use to take control over our world and
to create the environment that we want
but unfortunately we grow up we don't
know that we've been raised live through
by what we see hear smell taste and
touch we've been raised to be controlled
by what's going on outside as little
kids where you'll listen to what I'm
telling you where you'll look at this
you know and so it's all outside I think
we're we're raised in ignorance actually
there's a very small percentage of the
population that have a reasonably clear
understanding of who they are and what
they're capable of doing but the ones
that do are in the minority need
motivation watch top 10 with believe
Nations hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Bob Proctor and my take on his top 10
rules for success
enjoy
rule number two translate the future
into being the future must become the
present in the imagination of the one
who had wisely and consciously create
circumstances
I think right now everybody wants to
create circumstances because they don't
like the ones they find themselves in
but you see you cannot change the
circumstance you find yourself in you
can only change your perception of them
and when you do that you change the
circumstance so we say here the future
must become the present in the
imagination of the one who had wisely
unconsciously create circumstance we
must translate Vision into being
[Music]
thinking of into thinking from
imagination must Center itself in some
State and then view the world from that
state
see yourself where we want to be and
then be there
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world of fulfilled
desire
that is so cool
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world of fulfilled
desire so what are we doing we're
building a goal and then we see
ourselves already having accomplished a
goal
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world of fulfilled
desire already got it I don't have to
get it I've already got it
that's an intense perception
of the world of fulfilled desire in
other words you got it it's here
now think are you thinking from the end
are you thinking of the end if you're
thinking of the end you're thinking is
way out there if you're thinking from
the end you're part of it
see
the end result has already happened in
our mind
we're created beings we're God's highest
form of creation we can create in our
Consciousness the kind of person we want
to be and then be that person and that's
what he said here we must translate
Vision into being
so we don't just visualize it we be it
rule number three take risks I set a
goal in 1973 I set a goal that I was
going to build a company and upgrade all
over the world
I had left an angel Conan Corporation
and decided that I was going to do this
because I didn't agree with the way they
were doing it
people weren't really learning it fast
enough
and they wouldn't get involved in the
repetition we were selling recordings
but the recordings weren't working
because the people didn't understand how
to use them
so I decided I would leave and start my
own company
and I wrote down I'd build a company and
operate it all over the world I got a
call last night from Mikey about nine
o'clock something like that
and she told me that we were now
in every country in the world
now think of that
we had a broadcast going on here at 10
o'clock this morning some of you'd be
familiar with some of you may have been
on it and
that broadcast had attracted thousands
literally thousands of people
from every country in the world
the goal was reached
that moved meant this is really accurate
today we're only limited by weakness of
attention and Poverty of imagination
well my imagination was pretty well
exercised I don't have any difficulty
building huge ideas in my mind and just
figuring out how to do it
now stay with me here
the thing that's stopping you
from taking the risk that you want to
take
it's called a terror barrier
the way I'm going to explain this to you
I come up with sitting in a restaurant I
remember it was at a holiday and
restaurant
it was at Dixie and uh just south of the
401 Highway in Toronto a man asked me if
I would meet with him he had a problem
and I was going to show him how he could
solve the problem and he explained it so
I took a pen and some paper and what I'm
going to show you here is essentially
what I showed him
now look at this for a moment
there is the process you go through when
you're in a risk-taking vibration
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier and then to
Freedom
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier and then to
Freedom rule number four stop focusing
on negative news I think reason is
probably
it's the one that's spoken about by
almost all the great leaders yeah
they've all been completely unanimous
agreement that we become what we think
about
it's our reasoning factor that enables
us to think
um Fords is thinking is the hardest work
there is which is the probable reason so
few people engage in it Dr Ken McFarland
uh who's gone for a long time now but he
was a great educator down in Kentucky he
one time said two percent of the people
think three percent think they think and
95 percent would actually rather die
than things
now you know that sounds cute
but it's true
if you stop and listen
to what most people are saying it's
going to be fairly obvious they're not
thinking if you stand back and watch
what most people are doing it's fairly
obvious they're not thinking well they
would never say or do what they're doing
most people today have their television
on the news
and they're just soaking up all the
stuff
that's going on that's dominating the
media right now
so they've become a play thing for
what's going on outside
um
and that's why they're living in such
fear by consuming the media of whether
it's true or accurate or not true you're
you're being manipulated yeah it's not a
matter of whether it's true or not is
this how you want to spend your life
just listening to that
um
that doesn't mean you should deny it it
doesn't mean that you should say well
that's all false
um I don't know either it's true or
false it's just bad news I don't want to
be involved in it yeah am I aware that
it's there well you'd almost have to be
dead not to be aware that it's there but
that doesn't mean you have to spend your
time thinking on that um
well I would much rather activate some
of my creative faculties and do
something that's constructive also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
of the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five don't let fear
control you it's pretty well known today
there's a lot of fear in the world
people are wondering what's going to
happen we've gone through many tough
times if you study history
I was born during the Great Depression
so I was of an age then I remember some
of the things as a little kid
then we went into a world war and when
the depression ended
it was sort of like a theater where the
lights were out it was empty but the
lights started to come up and things
start to get brighter and of course they
became very bright
so the fear don't let fear control you
fear is a negative emotion
by following these principles you're
going to be on the other side of fear
where there's Faith there's a law of the
universe called polarity
that law decrease everything has an
opposite every negative has a positive
the truth is it's neither positive or
negative
it's our thinking that makes it so
everything just is we can make it what
we want
make up your mind now you're going to go
in the positive polarity you're going to
stay with me because that's where I'm
going
and there'll be a very bright future
let the fear go it isn't necessary the
cause of it is ignorance because of all
fear is ignorance rule number six build
your image if you want something you
haven't got you got to create a space
for it if it's in your own mind you've
got to let go of something
so what do we want to do let God we want
to let go of the image we've got for the
one we're going to build
now
I'm going to be honest with you when I
started to do this
um I tested it just
I thought I wonder if this really work
and I found that it really worked so I
went all out
and
you start out by writing
the image that you want to hold
I'll tell you how I did it
I am
I took various people that I really
admired
and I took some of the qualities that I
really admired in them and I'd write
them down
I was going to be like them but I was
going to develop a couple of these
qualities or habits when I was growing
up as a young guy it was during the
second World War
there was no men around no fathers
but one guy did have a father Donnie
Miller's father had was not well so he
couldn't go to the war
and
Donny's dad had a heart attack or he was
something it was I think it was a heart
attack
and so we never went around his place
because his dad wanted things quiet
they come around every place but not
Donny's place
I would watch Donny's dad walk up and
down the street
you see him go way up the street later
on you'd see him come back
he was always well dressed and he had
the calmest walk
there was no rush just a very calm walk
I visualized myself walking like him
he'll very rarely ever see me rushing
anywhere there's no need of it
you can be calm
so when I built my self-image
I built it around certain things Ray
Stanford always had money
I told you earlier I don't know how to
get into this thing now
always have some money
always
now
I hardly ever use it
because I really don't pay for very much
I get somebody in the company to order
whatever I want
but you see I never had any money Ray
always had a roll on him he would have a
role like that in his pocket all the
time
now there's about three thousand dollars
here it's not about three is three
thousand dollars here
see
well
I only earned four thousand dollars a
year at that time three thousand dollars
would have been a ton of money but
everybody has different little quirks
I like to carry money
I and it's probably because I never had
any
and now I have some money I want to
carry it but you see I started to do
that before I had any money
and I would take and I would put
phony money in a roll but I would have
the right thing on the outside it was
the thickness of it
my mind didn't know the difference I
knew intellectually the difference and
then shortly I didn't even pay any
difference to that it was the feel of it
I did different things I watched
different people I saw how this person
did this and somebody else did that
I am
I read a lot
so I read a lot of great self-help books
and
I literally did what some of these books
suggested
it wasn't just sometimes I did it
I would follow a rate to a T
um you'll very rarely see me without a
suit on
that's part of the paradigm
as part of the paradigm I don't care
what anybody else does how they dress
I'm always going to be dressed
I am mentally made up my mind one time
I'd be at least
if it wasn't the best dress one of the
best rich people in the room
why'd I do that I did that because I was
changing how I saw me
oh I saw me I had never gone to school I
had no money I had dumb jobs
and today
along with Sandy Gallagher I have a
company operates all over the world rule
number seven create space right here on
my desk I have sitting this little
hourglass
well you know I can't put anything where
that hourglass is until I get rid of it
and we find that we want things to come
into our life but we don't create room
for them
nature abhors a vacuum and I remember we
were
sitting in the living room having a cup
of coffee and just visiting and she said
do you mind if we go and sit in the
kitchen and I said none at all so
I asked her I said why are you doing sit
in the kitchen rather than she says I
can't stand that room I just hate living
in that sitting in that room she says I
hate those curtains that are on the
window and the dining room and the
drapes on the front window
and I said no you don't hate those Mark
I said you only have track things to you
that you love that you're in harmony
with I said if you really didn't love
them you get rid of them
which is them getting to put the
I'm going to put them there if I Get
Rhythm I said Mark
if you had something to put there you
couldn't put it there because you've
already got something there
and I said that's when I started
teaching the law of vacuum law
prosperity
certainly she went and got a chair and
got up and stood on she started taking
all these Curtains Down well done he was
wearing like a stuffed pig he said what
are you doing and she said I'm getting
rid of these
and she did
wasn't too long after I dropped in all
the furniture in the living room was
gone
it was like they were just moving into
the place
but then they got new curtains and then
they got new furniture and you know
everything in that business in that
house changed wasn't too long their own
business for themselves they're both
gone now but when they left they were
fairly well off they had a beautiful
place in Florida they'd go to in Winter
the family still runs their own business
I mean it was it was such a beautiful
thing to see and it was all and I tell
the story in here because it was all
about the vacuum law prosperity well
what have you got in your life that you
don't want or that you don't like or
what is it that you've got that you
really want to get rid of
you've got to get rid of this stuff get
rid of it give it away
see nature truly does a poor a vacuum
when you make space for the good that
you desire that's when the Good's going
to come most people don't make the space
for the good that they desire rule
number eight pay yourself first talk
about people paying themselves they pay
everything under the Sun but they don't
pay themselves
think of when you're on a plane
and the oxygen mask may drop down
there's a problem with oxygen in the
plane they will tell you if you have a
child with you put your own on first
because you can't look after the kids if
you haven't got your self looked after
well that's exactly the same with money
look after yourself first if you don't
pay yourself
you're soon gonna
teach yourself and just not do very well
rule number nine listen with your
emotions we are building a picture
in our mind here this is an idea
we could say it's a goal
then we impress that idea upon this part
of our personality
that's the idea in our mind
now what we've got to understand
is that this part of our mind the
subject of mind
is actually Universal intelligence
and this is really the way it is
when you press the idea upon your
subconscious mind
you are
universally everywhere
now to help you think of that
well here's a phone
let's suppose you're in uh okay
Buenos Aires
and
I'm right here
in North America Toronto
and I dial your number I've got you on
the phone
time and space means nothing because
I've got on to that frequency
and so you and I communicate we're
connected
one person's in Buenos Aires or you
could say Singapore you could say
Shanghai and another one is in New York
or in Toronto but they're connected why
the time and space means nothing because
you're dealing with energy
and you're dealing with laws
now when you impress this idea upon the
subconscious mind
the subconscious mind is universal
intelligence
and everything
anywhere in the universe
that's in harmony that is a frequency
understand that
that idea is a frequency it's operating
on a frequency
and so everything that's in harmony with
it begins to move toward it
because then Harmony is vibration and
you attract it
now
throw a slide up Scott
look here for a moment
Soren kikugard
wrote something really great on
intuition
he said listen you got to listen you
listen with your emotions
we can only get in touch with our own
source of intuition and wisdom
when we no longer depend upon others
opinions for our sense of identity or
worth
we all tend to worship something
the question is will we worship the god
of opinion or the god of our heart
I found I had less and less to say until
finally I became silent
and began to listen
I discovered in the silence
the voice of God
now look at
you're going to attract to you
everything that you require
to manifest the idea in your mind
thoughts will come to you
it's your intuition that Picks Them Up
and then act on them and just because
you've never gone there before you've
never done it before that's okay
this is where courage comes in
this is where awareness and wisdom comes
in
see intuition is the mental faculty
it go back to our slide Here For Mama
Scott intuition is here in our conscious
mind
it's one of our intellectual factors we
have perception
the will
reason
imagination memory and
intuition
right here
now intuition is that mental faculty on
a conscious level we pick up thoughts
that are flying our way
they're flying our way
what are they it's energy that's in
harmony with you
you've got on the frequency
of this good that you desire
and you're going to start attracting and
that's what Kierkegaard said we're going
to start listening
we listen with our emotions let's pay
attention to what's coming our way and
Rule Number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is don't be
limited by age I didn't like the idea
that when you've lived for so long
you've got to cut out you've got to stop
I thought hell I don't like that idea at
all and
first of all I think where
where I believe we're here to do God's
work God's work is creation
you know uh expansion Fuller expression
greater goodness
um
and if we're going to do that
we're going to be working at it all the
time we're here on this planet
we never stop so AIDS should have no
bearing on them
we put a couple of million dollars into
this and somebody said how old are you
I think I was probably 83 when I started
to break ground
they said you're 83 and you're gonna
spend two million dollars building a
studio
and I said yeah like why not
I mean you see we let things that really
have no concern we let them bother us we
let them control us age is a dumb thing
to let control you
it's our thinking that controls
everything
that's the one point every great leader
agreed on we become what we think about
well what's a person thinking I'm
thinking if I get old I gotta stop well
then you'll stop or I'm thinking well if
I've been here a long time I've got a
lot of experience I want to utilize that
experience to keep me going as long as I
am here
why did a guy like me change I didn't
believe there was an emotional or
capricious God reached out and said
let's give Bob a chance I didn't believe
that
I thought Something's Happened what's
happened
well I spent nine and a half years
studying
with some absolutely brilliant people
now I formed a good habit over that time
I picked good mentors and that's very
important you can use these films as a
mentor you can you can let me be your
mentor
General bathroom heard it said people
that have been gone for a couple of
thousand years can help you more than
somebody that's alive today and I get a
lot of help from people that have been
gone for a long time through their books
writings so you could use this series as
a mentor but a habit I form right from
the first person that helped me
Ray
Ray Stanford he said do exactly what I
tell you and for some reason I decided I
would I didn't question him I just did
it he said do it until you find out I'm
lying or I don't know what I'm talking
about foreign
Do What I suggest in these films until
you find out I'm lying or I don't know
what I'm talking about I don't lie
and believe me I do know what I'm
talking about
many years ago they said by their right
results you'll know them or by their
fruits you'll know them I searched every
day and every time I picked a new mentor
and I did pick new mentors I did exactly
what they said
it was difficult at first because what I
was really doing was changing habit
patterns
but they were teaching me things they
were teaching me information that the
average person may never learn
I developed a very close rapport with
them
and they were brilliant people every one
of them very accomplished
that is a good rule if you want to do
something go to someone who is
demonstrated by results they do know
what they're talking about
ask them what should you do
then do exactly what they tell you now I
know that works
because I'm still doing it and I do it
every day
I don't think you determine what your
purpose is I think you discover what
your purpose is there's a difference
determining indicates deciding
um
and I don't think you decide I think if
you go about it the right way you
discover it
like there's some people that should be
painting all day they're great artists
I think Michelangelo was obviously a
great artist great Sculptor
I mean that was his purpose
in his life
well I believe my purpose is doing what
I'm doing
your purpose is why you get out of bed
in the morning do you know why you get
up well most people say well it's to go
to work well that'd be a good reason to
stay in bed you know you say Well
everybody's doing it that would be
another reason to stay in bed if you're
ever doing what everybody's doing you're
probably going in the wrong direction
your purpose is your reason for living
what you want to do is sit down and
maybe take a pen
and a pad
and then ask yourself what do I really
love doing now you may have to spend a
while at this
you might get up an hour early every
morning
and go sit under a tree somewhere if
you're in a nice climate
or pick a favorite chair someplace where
you're not going to be disturbed
and totally relax
and say
if I could spend my life doing something
what do I really love doing
now since you don't ask yourself that
question every day it might take a while
for this answer to come to the surface
but it comes
to your consciousness
and it may take a while you may have to
do this every morning for
three months
but it would be well invested the time
how many times have you had somebody say
to you hey have you got a menopause
we got a minute
they don't want a minute
I want you to think about that
I read a poem one time I said I have
only just a minute only 60 seconds in it
was forced upon me I can't refuse it I
didn't seek it and I didn't choose it
but it's up to me to use it I must
suffer if I lose it give a count if I
abuse it it's only a tiny little minute
but eternity is in it
well anyway I thought I'm gonna put this
on a video and I'm just going to share
it with everybody just this one little
part of the seminar I'm making
I want you to look at this sand timer
and let this I want you to think about
your life the sand in the top of the
glass represents the future the sand in
the bottom of the glass represents the
past
now you know we know what's in the past
and yet we can't do anything about it do
you know what the trick is you don't
know how much Sand's in the top of the
glass you may think you have a lot you
might only have a little
then again you may think you have a
little and you might have a lot
when I was a little boy I was raised by
my grandmother and I don't know when I
was little guy for she was probably 60
but as long as I can remember grandma
would say and I'll soon be going there
I'll send begun well you know we loved
her she was really an angel of God but
we thought she was never going to go she
lived to be 94. for 30 some years I'll
soon be gone
she didn't think she had much time left
she had 34 years left
now about the same time I had a buddy of
mine Bob Yates he was just 16. and bang
he run into the abutment of a bridge and
his life was snuffed out if you had
asked him a half hour before how much
Sandy had left he would have said at
least a half a century he didn't have a
half an hour see the trick is we don't
know how much sand we have left
the future
we don't know the past it's gone now the
only thing you can deal with is what's
right here right now and if you look the
sand is always moving
now think of this you see I was working
on that and then I was working on a
graph I've got here on my computer
and I'm thinking of the time somebody
said hey have you got a minute
well they don't really want to mend
do you know if you were earning fifty
thousand dollars a year in minutes 42
cents
a half hour is 12.50 if we take that
ahead a bit if you're earning eighty
thousand dollars a year a minute 67
cents
half hours twenty dollars
if you're earning a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year got a minute it
costs you a dollar 25 a minute
a half hours 37.50 so if you see if
somebody said you want to stop for a cup
of coffee
well if you're earning a quarter of a
million dollars a year a minute is two
dollars and eight cents
half hours sixty two dollars and fifty
cents
and then of course you got the coffee to
pay for on top of that
so you see the point is this
this is all we've got right here right
now we don't know how much we have left
in the future but we do know what we've
got now and I have found that people
that win are the people who make up
their mind they're not going to waste
the minutes they're going to be
productive they're going to make it
happen every minute he said that success
was the progressive realization of a
worthy ideal anyone that has a goal and
they're moving towards it they're
successful most people think that you're
successful if you have a lot of money
quite often you have a lot of money if
you're successful but it isn't I
wouldn't say Mother Teresa has a lot of
money okay but she's a pretty successful
lady
so it's um okay so that barrier well
there's there's a couple of them okay I
think there's two barriers one is our
conditioning the conditioning that takes
place in our subconscious mind from the
time we're infants
all we can do is act and talk like the
people around us that's why we learn the
language we learned that there was 10
languages spoken in our home we'd learn
10 languages without any trouble there's
usually one and that's the only one we
ever learn and we grow old and we think
well I couldn't learn another language
we could learn 100 if we wanted to you
can do anything but I think we're
conditioned we have a real strong
conditioning usually with not some very
good ideas
and then that that's the the barrier
that's inside is the one that's outside
of us as our environment we have a
tendency to act like everybody around us
and if you think about this it does make
a lot of sense because if you study
statistics 95 of the people live their
entire life and never live the way they
want to live
you know that 90.5 percent of the
population in this country let's say in
North America okay the richest continent
in the history of the world they'll work
productively let's say for 40 of their
65 years okay and they'll end up with
hardly any money
there's got to be something wrong
so there's no five percent of the people
end up financially comfortable or
independent
are you trying to depress this Bob
because that's uh no actually I think
it's I think it's quite an exciting idea
because you see the idea behind it is
that anybody can win
anyone at all but if we start studying
these statistics I think we'll arrive at
the conclusion geez I better start
thinking for myself rather than follow
everybody most people they get a job
they look around you see how everybody
else is doing their work and they start
doing it the same way they should stop
and think I wonder if any of these
people know what they're doing is there
a better way to do it well don't we have
a need to fit in I mean we don't want to
we don't want to stand out we don't want
to get fired we don't want to make waves
exactly exactly just fall into line you
know take a number be like everybody
around you know that'd be great in the
animal kingdom
but human beings aren't supposed to live
that way I think we should make a few
waves we should maybe Stand Out be
different not not for the sake of being
different okay but because we are
different we all think different
thoughts and I believe we should start
to think and build images in our mind of
what we'd like to do and then set out
and do it okay Emerson did that Edison
did that Marconi did that and Samuel
Morse did that uh buckminister Fuller
did that we could go on and on and on
okay we're different they stood out they
made a few waves you should seek
failures
see if you're playing it safe you're not
going to win
if you're playing it safe
like that old saying you know you're a
top and you're a little girl better to
be safe than sorry well that's a bunch
of crap it's not better to be safe than
sorry
it's by trying things that you figure
out how far you can go
you got to get outside the box
like it's reported Edison
tried 3 000 ways before he built the
incandescent light he he said he didn't
fail three thousand times he said there
was three thousand different steps to
building a light bulb
well there's different steps to get to
where you're going and I really do treat
winning and losing exactly the same I do
not let it upset me do you think that's
a big part of why you're so successful
well it's part of why I enjoy it
um yeah I think it is because I I try
anything like if if I'm into an idea
the idea of losing never enters my mind
see I have worked with Giants
I have the Good Fortune of working with
Sir Edmund Hillary
he was the first man to stand on top of
the world
and I worked with him on three different
occasions
and the only difference in Ed Hillary
and Bob Proctor is in his his size now
he's gone now but he was a big man when
he shook hands with me his hand wrapped
right around mine I felt like a dwarf
you know and
and talked into him like it never
entered his mind he wouldn't get to the
top of the mountain but he failed in
1951 he failed in 1952
it wasn't until 1953 that he got to the
top of the mountain now people had died
for centuries trying to do that
but he said I know if I could see it in
here
I could hold it out here Stella man
wrote that in a book if you can see it
in your head you can hold it in your
hand
and that's right
and if you're not prepared to lose
you're never going to win because you're
always playing it safe
and there's no there's no reward in that
look at these two men do you know who
they are most people don't they're just
a couple of ordinary guys one they're
both gone now but one was an ordinary
beekeeper in Auckland New Zealand and
the other a sherpa guide from over
around Nepal now there's Mount Everest
do you know for thousands of years
people have tried to get to the top of
Mount Everest people died doing it it
was believed it couldn't be done people
tried but they didn't know how and so
they quit there's a closer look at the
mountain and where they placed their
flag they planted that flag in the
mountain now this is the two of them
after they come down the mountain and
you know something when they started
they did not know how they didn't know
how to get to the top of the mountain
and that's what stops most people
because they don't know how as little
kids we'd go mummy Daddy I want this and
they say now how are you going to do
that well as a little kid you don't know
how to do it but they did it in 1953 on
the 29th of May they were the first two
to get to the top of that mountain they
stood right on top of the world do you
know there's been over a thousand people
do it since then I watched a young woman
on Canadian television being interviewed
not very big
she had just come back from going to the
top of Mount Everest And the reporter
asked her they said how does it feel now
that you conquered the mountain she we
didn't conquer the mountain that
mountain can't be conquered we conquered
the limitations that are within
ourselves
select a person who is already doing
something that you'd like to do get to
know that person
go to The Experts for advice don't ask
the person next door your mother father
or brother or the guy that works beside
you because they don't necessarily know
there's no point in asking a person how
to earn a lot of money if they're only
earning ten thousand a year they don't
know they knew they'd probably be
earning a lot
it's like don't go to a sick doctor if
you want to get healthy okay so you find
someone that you can go to for advice
get a real good book and lock into that
book and start to study it like
I've had this one that looks like a
Bible you know but this is Napoleon
Hill's book Think and Grow Rich I've
been reading this thing now for 23 years
I'll probably read it for another 23
years I get another good book that I
brought over here today it's called The
Power of your subconscious mind I'm not
getting a commission for selling this
the authors
dead now he's been gone for a couple of
years but Dr Joseph Murphy wrote this
book The Power of your subconscious mind
and that's probably one of the best
books that you're ever going to find
because you're going to learn something
about your mind when you read this book
okay now I read a lot of books I've got
probably a thousand books sitting in my
Den at home in my library but the one
that I care I carry it everywhere I go
and I read it all the time is thinking
go rich I never stop reading it now
where's the value for you to reread that
and read that I mean you must you must
know it well enough that I think I could
probably recite it verbatim but the
secret is I once read in a book where it
said when you read a good book through
the second time you don't see something
in it that you didn't see before you see
something in yourself that wasn't there
before you see when I read this I create
a a greater awareness many years ago I
read a book by Terry Cole Whittaker it
was a classic what you think of me is
none of my business think of the amount
of time that is wasted on negative
energy wondering what other people think
of you what they think of you really
doesn't make any difference it's what
you think of you that makes a difference
so as you go through the day don't worry
about what other people think of you
just say I'm all right I'm God's highest
form of creation see this line
that's called The Terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it and on the other
side of the terror barrier is something
we call Freedom
and you know
very few people get through that Terror
barrier it's rather sad freedom is
available to everyone there isn't anyone
that cannot live the way they want to
live
okay
why don't they
why don't they
they don't know
and they don't even know they don't know
now I'm going to show you why people
experience buyer's remorse when they buy
something they really want and then they
back away or they go to move and they
don't they go to change jobs and they
don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't why
fear causes them to stay where they are
they Joel The X rep represents the
unknown factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we had the ability to choose
whether they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the Paradigm
now here's an important point the
Paradigm controls the vibration of this
thing we call our body our body is a
molecular instrument that's really what
it is it's a mass of molecules and a
very high speed of vibration
the vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now they choose thoughts that harmonize
with the vibration they're in so they
feel comfortable they may not like the
results but they're comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting X-Type
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
Paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison to walk out into
Freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person
X-Type conditioning X-Type vibration the
power is flowing into them and for some
strange reason from Left Field above
bone in comes a y-type idea what is a
y-type idea the y-type idea represents
anything that you might want to do that
you're not doing
yet might be moved to another city
changed jobs sell the house buy the farm
whatever it may be
ask the little girl for the date
ask the guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the why
idea but as long as the why ideas just
in the conscious mind it's just going to
be an intellectual exercise it's never
going to happen
so how do we make it happen well that's
when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power Flows In
and what do they do they got the y-type
idea
now for some strange reason they know
that they've got to get emotionally
involved that they're going to act on
that idea they don't understand what's
going to happen but clearly understand
this your central nervous system is the
most complex electrical system in the
universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling it would make the
electrical system in a supercomputer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mine that's when
all hell breaks loose because the body
moves in to an extra XY vibration it's
not in the X vibration not the one that
we're comfortable with may not like the
results but we're comfortable no on a
conscious level everything's going crazy
on a conscious level we experience doubt
that doubt turns into an emotion called
fear and that fear is expressed through
the body as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that Terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like at least they're
comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that Terror
barrier see the terror barrier is going
Beyond where you're at going to a new
level I'm going to tell you something
when I set a goal
if if it doesn't scare and excite me at
the same time I know I'm going in the
wrong direction now I also understand
that my Paradigm is going to try and get
me to bounce back to where I was it
doesn't want me to move ahead
I don't want to live there
ice lived there for the first 26 years
of my life and for the last 50 I had a
phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and I want you to do the
same thing understand what I've just
said I'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the Y
idea that moved their body into a
different vibration on a conscious level
their experiencing some crazy stuff they
start to doubt their ability and they'll
never be able to pay for it basically
experience fear the fear expresses
itself as anxiety
and dang you bounce off that Terror
barrier and you're right back
oh I might not be earning much here but
I know what it is
I I I would love to move there but I'm
comfortable here I think I'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't you know what to do say I'm going
to get rid of all that I understand it's
there but I don't want any part of it
and I'm going to go crashing right
through that Terror barrier
now does that get rid of the X energy no
that's energy
is still there
you see but at least you're over into
Freedom you made the move you did it and
if you continue to feed the right
information into your mind keep feeding
that y idea keep getting emotionally
involved in the Y idea you're there
you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the Paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know where you're living
in Freedom you're living where you want
to live
Fire's remorse
is when you cancel the sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier I'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell say
so true
they cave you fear to enter holds the
treasure you seek many years ago
I read we're Napoleon Hill pointed out
that the imagination is the most
marvelous
miraculous
inconceivably powerful force that the
world has ever known
and you know the average individual uses
the imagination if they use it at all
against themselves they imagine what
they don't want they imagine problems
coming
let's begin to use our imagination the
way God meant it to be used it's the
greatest creative faculty that we
possess and we can build anything we
want with it I want you to wander around
your home or possibly your office and
take a look at all of the conveniences
that you have there that you didn't have
let's say two years five years ten years
ago
25 years ago do you know that every one
of them without exception was first
created
in the mind of one individual with their
imagination
do you know you can use your imagination
to go into the future and bring it into
the present
that's what all highly successful people
do they see where they want to go and
then they act like the person they want
to become
was William James from Harvard's advice
he says is the actors technique act like
the person you want to become how do you
do that
use your imagination of course
you see it's a strange phenomena but the
greatest gift we've got is used
very well up till the ages of four or
possibly five the little child
we always wonder what's going on in
their mind they're using their
imagination they're building wonderful
pictures in their mind
then they get to school and Wham like
that it comes to an abrupt halt it's
called not paying attention
daydreaming
well
what they were really doing was
exercising a phenomenal mental faculty
you see we can see here smell taste
touch therefore our physical benefit as
long as we're living in a physical body
and corresponding with the material
world we will use our sensory factors
but you know I have a couple of little
dogs at home that can hear see I'll
taste and touch
we've got higher faculties you have
perception the will
memory intuition reason and Imagination
these marvelous tools
we can take our imagination and build an
image in our mind of how we want to live
block out what's going now don't let
your present results have anything to do
with this
just what you want and it's with your
imagination that you will build it
everything that we have the camera that
I'm speaking to right now was first
created in the mind of one individual
think of how our world's changed
you see we were gifted with these higher
faculties
we're God's highest form of creation
we were created in God's image we were
given creative faculties to use
and you know they're only used by two or
three percent of the population
almost inconceivable that we people
would wander around with so much power
and potential
and squander it see the average person
literally tiptoes through life hoping
they make it safely to death
it's such a shame and it doesn't have to
be that way
I think we have giant corporations and
little weed creative departments
primary reason for that is the average
individual
really does not believe that they're
creative
everyone's creative and no one is more
creative than another it's just that
some have chosen to use their creative
faculties to a greater degree than
others
[Music]
imagination your imagination
what do you want how do you really want
to live
build the picture in your mind there's a
power that is Flowing to and through you
a creative
unadulterated power
it can be photographed leaving your body
way back in the 30s Simeon curly in the
Russian photographer perfected a form of
Photography where you can actually
photograph a person's body and you will
see the energy glowing from them
well that energy flows into your mind
and it's the images you build in your
mind that's going to dictate the
vibration that this instrument are
living in is in and the vibration on a
conscious level is called feeling make
certain that you exercise your
imagination daily build beautiful images
in your mind of how you want to live and
then hold those pictures there and live
that way
the imagination
the greatest nation in the world the
imagination
you've got one it's a marvelous creative
tool
deals with the invisible side of your
personality
see no one will ever really see you
they'll only see your body and they'll
see you the great work that you do make
certain that your work is great work and
if you keep your imagination alive keep
it active
you're going to have a phenomenal life
you know life can get better every day
and it will get better every day
it's through the proper use
of your imagination
what a wonderful idea
this is Bob Proctor thank you do you
know that the law of attraction is
always working it's like the law of
gravity if I let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is law of
gravity anything heavier than Earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work well I use a
diagram to explain the mind now let this
circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body now I want you to
think of this for a moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration if you looked at your
body through a microscope you'd see that
energy dancing right before your eyes
and here's something that will keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it the body does not stop
moving if you go to a funeral parlor and
pick up the remains and look at it you
will see it moving and if it wasn't
moving how would it ever change the Dust
you move into your body and you will
move up and it's how you use your mind
that's going to dictate the vibration
you're in now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here and that separates the conscious
mind from the subconscious mind now this
subconscious mind has been programmed
when you're a little baby this is the
way it was or just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm now a
paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for Generations now I'm going
to say that the Paradigm is X Type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think and you can
think anything you want to think
and as you think you build ideas there's
a power that's flowing into your
Consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
as it flows in you will start thinking
and you'll probably think X-Type
thoughts therefore you're going to be in
an X-Type vibration
and that will produce X-Type results now
it's the results you want to change and
to change the results you're going to
have to change what you attract you see
the thoughts that you think control the
vibration that you're in vibration is
nothing but an idea it's a law of the
universe everything vibrates nothing
rests we live in an ocean of motion and
it's the thoughts that you're thinking
that you impress upon your subconscious
mind that control the vibration the
body's in and that dictates how you act
but it also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's a
infinite number of frequencies but you
and I operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned into the vibration you're in now
it's the Paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking but that
doesn't do anything you've got to change
the paradigm and if you don't change the
Paradigm nothing happens now talking
about paradigms is another subject we'll
do that at another time but it's the
thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the Paradigm that's
causing the problem you can think a why
type thought which is totally different
than the X-Type conditioning it isn't
going to go anywhere because when you go
to get emotionally involved and this is
the emotional mind when you go to get
emotionally involved with that white
type done the Paradigm will kick it out
you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this the Paradigm in the
thinking control the vibration you're in
and the vibration you're in is going to
dictate what you attract
people that are in a poverty
Consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
Paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this you've got to
change the vibration you're in and your
whole world changes listen
in 1961 the man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what I tell you he was
giving me y-type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but I did
exactly what he said and you know
something my income went from 4 000 to
175 000 in a year and then I took it
over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what I'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here and another
lesson I'm going to show you how to
change the Paradigm when you change the
Paradigm the change in results is
automatic you know why you start to
attract something that something
different and what we want to do is
program in positive information and
eliminate the negative I'm going to show
you how to do that
a law of attraction
you attract according to the vibration
you're in this thing we live in is a
molecular structure your body is a
massive energy do you know if you put
your body in front of an infrared
television camera in a completely dark
room your whole being would be nothing
but a glistening radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good we're in a negative vibration
we want to feel good move into a
positive vibration stop and think of
what you're grateful for but understand
this you will never attract to you
wealth happiness health until you get
the Paradigm get you on that frequency
people don't resist change people resist
being changed yes we've got to change
ourselves we've got to build a new image
a picture in our mind we've got to see
ourselves the way we want to be and then
we have to live with it that's you go to
the gym workout that's what you do you
build a picture how you want to see this
arm this arm and you build that picture
and then you build the body well you
build the life in your mind take your
pen and write out how you want to live
and always start by writing I'm so happy
and grateful now that and the second you
write it you've got it intellectually
the moment you impress it upon your
emotional mind you've got it emotionally
and it's only a period of time till it
manifests on the physical plane yeah
Spirit works from a higher to a lower
potential habits
good habits will give you results to
stick bad habits will destroy everything
I have some bad habits that's right all
my habits are not great so if you've got
some bad habits don't feel bad so does
your next door neighbor so does your
Mentor your coach so does your mother
and father if they're alive so does
everyone and the trick of life is to
replace a bad habit with a good habit
I used to hang around bars all the time
and one day I went in I picked up a
glass and I looked around and I thought
there are bums in here
and then it dawned on me I'm always here
I learned something I put the glass down
and I said I'm never coming back here
again and I'm never going to drink this
and I never did that was a long time ago
but you know what I did I went from
spending all my money on the bar to the
racetrack and I started to bet it all on
horses so I went from making somebody
with a bar get wealthy and then I
started to feed the horses and one day I
woke up and I learned something if you
don't consciously and deliberately
replace a bad habit with a good habit
you will automatically create another
bad habit now what is a habit a habit is
an idea that has been planted in the
garden of your subconscious mind
and then repetitively fed for a
sufficient period of time that you act
on it without giving any thought to it
I'll give you an example I want you to
write now mentally imagine you're
pulling on your underwear in the morning
what foot do you put in first
I put my right foot in if I tried to put
my left foot in my underwear first I'd
stagger and I'd fall over
you may say what's this got to do with
it it's got everything to do with it why
do I put my right foot you may put your
left certainly a lot of people do well
when I was just a little gapper didn't
have a clue of how to put underwear on
my mother or my grandmother or my father
or somebody came along and they had the
underwear I read put your foot in here
you're rather [ __ ]
what did they do they had the underwear
prepared as if they were going to put it
on
and so pretty soon I was doing it like
they were doing it they threw repetition
planted the idea in my hand in my mind
well now think of this
you don't just form habits of how to get
dressed you form habits to do everything
that you do and some of them are not
that productive
any idea that you keep dwelling on and
impressing upon your subconscious mind
becomes fixed in the subconscious mind a
habit is nothing but an idea that's
fixed in the subconscious mind that you
act on without giving any conscious
thought
many years ago I went in to train the
Prudential Insurance Company of America
their agents I ended up training all of
their agents and I only got them to do
two things this is in the early 70s I
got them to form the habit of being in
front of a prospect before 9 A.M and ask
everybody they talk to to purchase a
hundred thousand dollars worth of
insurance I said you don't have to sell
them just give them the opportunity to
say no
you know the sales in that company went
up by hundreds of millions of dollars I
had a retired VP tell me he thought it
was a billion
just changing two habits
what habit you want to change I'm
forever checking out habits I've got I'm
in the habit right now of changing my
diet and you know something I've been
doing it for going on three weeks it's
getting easier but it's still not that
easy I still like to Retro bird eat some
of that when nobody's looking
doesn't work doesn't work I'm looking
what habit are you going to form and you
shouldn't try and form more than two at
once it'll become too big and too heavy
and you won't form any
make up your mind you're going to do it
every day every day every day
until you don't have to think about it
and then you'll automatically do it I
guarantee you this idea will change your
life think about it all day because that
is definitely an idea that will give you
results that will stick right now I'm
standing in the middle of my library
this is my favorite place to know Earl
Langdale said if you surround your mind
with greatness some of it's going to rub
off well hopefully some of it is rubbed
up on me I have maybe three or four
thousand books here on the Shelf they're
all in alphabetical order by author
they're all cataloged so I know where to
find something just like that I go by
authors more than the title of the book
do you know that when I started studying
these books I really didn't know very
much about anything I had two months
High School I was 26 years old I had a
bad work record a bad attitude and and
virtually no experience and you know in
a relatively short period of time I am
gone went from 475
000 a year then it went over a million
I'm going to share some information with
you that it could change the direction
of your life like night and day
and when I say that I want you to really
stop and take a look at your life
take an honest look at your life I I was
thinking just before I start to make
this we have actually been conditioned
to kid with ourselves to lie to
ourselves to
um not really take an honest look at the
results we're getting
I want you to take a real honest look at
your results
and when you look at them ask yourself
am I living the way I really want to
live
you see most people aren't one of the
first questions I ask a person that
comes to work with me I want to know
what's the most they've ever earned in a
year now I really don't care what the
answer is but I want to know what the
answer is because you see
if
if a person says the most they've ever
earned in years fifty thousand dollars I
know where their mind is programmed
um if they tell me the most they've ever
earned is 250 000 I know where they're
programmed
and then I want to find out what they
want
and I know then what has to shift
because their mind is programmed and if
they're really going to live the way
they want to live they
um they've got to change the program
and if they don't change the program
then nothing really happens there's a
boss and there's a leader leader get
people excited about improving the
quality of whatever it is themselves
their work whatever they're doing
people follow leaders because they want
to
people don't follow our leaders because
they have to that becomes a form of
dictatorship and that never works the
great leaders people want to follow
and
leaders inspire you leaders pull a very
bust out of you leaders know how to look
inside and bring the best of you to the
surface cause you to look at the higher
side of your own personality
what the world always is looking for its
leader like it's silly to ask who's
going to lead the leader is going to
leave and the leader just automatically
emerges if they through 50 of us into a
committee
and say you don't elect the leader you
may electron but the leader is going to
lead and it probably isn't the one
that's elected
yeah so true and everybody knows how
they know how to get the best out of
people I want to talk to you about where
you're going and what you want to do
with your life
you see most people never go after what
they want because they don't know every
step they have to take to get there I
want you to think of a person going up
the side of a wall of ice now the Only
Rule for reaching a goal that you have
to know
is knowing where you're going and
knowing that you're going to get there
you do not have to know how you're going
to get there
now pay attention to this for a moment
imagine the climber has all his
equipment he's got his crampons he's got
his climbing rope his Hardware his ice
axes
how does he get to the top he's standing
on the ground and he's looking at maybe
a hundred foot vertical wall of ice he
looks up and he has absolutely no idea
the path that he's going to take he just
sees himself at the top
he reaches up and he puts one pick in
and then another pick then he raises one
foot and then the other now he's not
standing on the ground any longer he's
suspended on the wall on a vertical wall
of ice that goes up for a hundred feet
he adapts to the changes that is taking
place in his environment and then and
only then does he see the next step and
he moves this pick then this pick then
this foot then this foot now that's how
he gets to the top a step at a time and
that's how you're going to get to your
goal you just have to know the first
step to take and when you take that step
you're going to find that your
conditions your circumstance and
environment will change then you see how
you have to make the next step it's a
matter of adapting all the time you only
have to know two things you have to know
where you're going and you have to know
that you're going to get there you've
got to see it in your mind now this is
the beautiful scenario this is what it's
all about
save that in your mind and think of it
often think every time you think of your
goal and you're trying to figure out how
you're going to do it think of that
vertical all of ice what's the next step
that's all you really have to know one
step at a time
and you'll get to wherever you're going
that's how Hillary got to the top of
Mount Everest you know in Napoleon
Hill's book
Think and Grow Rich he said now right
here we come to a rather strange fact we
tend to minimize the things we can do
the goals we can accomplish and for some
equally strange reason we think other
people can accomplish things that we
cannot and he points out that there's a
difference between wishing for a thing
and being ready to receive them said no
one's ready for a thing until they
believe that they can acquire it the
State of Mind must be belief and not
near hope or wish now he goes under
Consciousness he said open-mindedness is
essential to believe closed minds will
not Inspire Faith courage horribly when
I was 26 I had a man that sat down with
me and he said why don't you change the
way you're living
it never entered my mind that I could
and looking back
and thinking about I think there's all
kinds of people wandering the planet
there's all kinds of athletes that are
not getting the results they want and
they don't know they can change them
right only one person can change there's
only one person in the whole universe
that can change Bob and that's Bob yeah
there's only one person can change David
that's Dave
you know we get inspired by other people
we get help from other people but we've
got to do it ourselves and he gave me
Think and Grow Rich and he said if you
do exactly what I tell you you can give
anything you want well I didn't believe
that
but he was so adamant about I believed
he believed him
and so
I started to listen to him
and I set a goal I wanted some money I
wanted 25 000 now this was in 1961 so it
was more money than it is today but I
didn't even know anyone with twenty five
thousand dollars he said listen write it
on a card keep reading the book keep
doing what I tell you so I started to
hear people talking about earning money
and
there was one guy said there's good
money cleaning floors you should clean
floors well I wasn't proud I'd clean
floors and he said but you should do it
for yourself now for somebody else so he
told me where I could buy a used floor
machine some buckets and mops but I had
to borrow those thousand dollars well I
was at the point where nobody wanted to
touch me with money and I often say I
wouldn't have lent it to me right
because I wouldn't pay it back not that
I didn't want to I just couldn't
but I found a guy and he lent me the
thousand dollars
I have a question because I know you
when you borrowed that thousand because
you owed people money already you
explain that to people you know you were
just finding yourself but did you have a
different feeling about when you
borrowed this thousand that quite
possibly you were actually going to be
able to just to pay this back this time
or something if I hadn't had that
feeling I wouldn't have got the money I
got it from a guy I knew his name Al
Kuiper he was running and I didn't know
him he had a Trust Company it was like a
bank on Dan Fourth Avenue in Toronto and
I went in I read a book where it says go
to One bank and then give me go to
another one well I ended up sitting in
his office and he said where do you want
this money for son
and I told him I was going to build a
cleaning company it was going to be big
I had a dream and
I had to explain it all to me he said I
think you'll do it I'm going to lend you
the money
Faith but I knew what I was doing this I
had a picture I had a dream you see yep
and
within a year I was earning 175 000 a
year
I had my billing up to fifteen thousand
dollars a month working for myself less
than five years we were working in
Toronto Montreal Boston Cleveland
Atlanta and London England I had my own
company opening offices all over the
place
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome pretend
more amazing rules from Joe dispenza
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there your personality
creates your personal reality that's it
and your personality is made up of how
you think how you act and how you feel
so the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality